he's the best he's the best way back
l'amour I should know today everybody hi
reject nation Greg John we're gonna
watch a patron video request today one
of our reward tiers is whatever video
you request we must definitely do and
it's a music video
oh it's artists is gonna get blocked on
YouTube alright
and it's probably in an age restriction
because of the title here ybn I don't
know who this is don't know this rapper
ybn I guess is like an online rap
collective and then Corte is one of
their members okay old and word Jay cool
1985 response yeah Jay Cole dropped an
album recently with a lot of advice for
the new generation of hip-hop and I
guess this is a response to the new
generation of hip-hop ain't as cool as
the Golden Age or is it that's the
debate
everybody hates Tupac and Biggie now
this page for video requests comes from
none other than Jasmine Holmes Jasmine
Holmes you are a beautiful woman from
what I can tell from this tiny little
profile pic we have of you here if we
can get an actual photo if you could
sense a John's account that'd be great
yeah Jasmine actually lives all the way
out in Utah where there's always so many
fun things to do we make our living off
of the internet so it's very challenging
I appreciate the job you do and she's
actually also born in September 8 5 days
after my birthday and she is 1991 one
year after my birth so Jasmine we have a
lot in common
us virgos got to stick together Virgo
means virgin I might have that applied
to my life but a woman as beautiful as
you highly doubt it but I'm not gonna
say anything more because I'm not in the
mood to get tweeted at this virgin gets
in a lot of trouble anyway let's watch
this world star just be my thug look the
entire time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] diamond chain with the big rocks
car DB guy
[Music]
there's some bars on that what's such a
sweet song yeah you know some real love
letter to romantic the older generation
yeah definitely he thanks for all your
guidance guys I'm not aware of this
discussion that's happening right now
it's been an old rap and new rap modern
rap and yeah you know we always see
something like that in like movies and
stuff and of course that happens in
music all the time but I haven't heard
it specifically about rap music
landscape is changing the music is
changing and the images and the culture
is all changing and there's been sort of
a rift you know there's been a big
backlash lately of younger fans and
artists both being like the old icons
are overrated there's more to hip-hop
than just people like Tupac or notorious
b.i.g sit down and let yes Paul I like
his approach the sort of like we need a
balanced sort of approach yeah there are
some points that you guys have but also
I think you should sit down and listen
to us for a second because this is an
art form for everybody and this is how
we all reap the rewards - yeah we need a
balance like the moon and the Sun
exactly as it says yeah that's why we
got chordae and then we have totally
this black and white going together
people that's the collab track that we
need yeah I think Macklemore should have
a good amount of messages for the hip
hop ya know what they should what it was
like being a black kid struggling yeah I
like the rap because it's kind of
leaning on how none of this is black and
white out here in LA and one of my
bookmarked stations on my radio
number-three 93.5 kada is like
old-school hip hop when I listen to that
rap yeah it's very different I prefer
the beats of today the specific music of
today but the lyrics that were big back
then don't seem as strongly prevalent
especially on the radio like the kind of
rap that we catch on the radio is the
very generic basic rhyme schemes yeah
stuff that's gonna reach the widest
amount of
as a pretty simple hook there's been a
lot of lamentation lately that lyrical
hip-hop is not really the zeitgeist
it's a moment yeah I mean it's there is
there like this is there but it's not as
in the mainstream as we'd like it to be
like that's a big part of what made raps
so influential like he's even talking
about how back then people thought it
was just a fad that people thought that
it wasn't gonna be something that really
stuck around but it was a poetry behind
the rap that has allowed rap to become
so influential now it's the number one
genre but what's made it become such a
number one genre is not what you really
hear anymore on the radio you know yeah
it's changed a lot why would you even
know ice back we do weird your grandma
where do your grandma man the flow bots
guy yeah they've put out a few albums I
think I'm all about white rappers
I know use some Machine Gun Kelly ticket
I mean so why would I rather listen to
Tupac or Mike Shinoda
they're both good let's face it Shinoda
better than all he's got some pretty
cool bars under the new album what he's
saying here is that it's not black and
white like there are some terrible
things that have happened from the
old-school generation one in some form
are her generation to there's greatness
in darkness and at all we just got to
find that happy medium which I don't
think in the entertainment industry you
really ever find out you can preach it
and there will be people who find it I
find it very difficult to believe that
we will get to a point where the
majority are like you know we found a
great balance that's just the way the
world works though and maybe this
conversation is very strong right now
it's always gonna be that way the thing
is rap it's one of the later John Rizzo
wears like rock and roll and all that
came way before it's like I'm sure when
the the British Invasion happened there
were plenty of people going music it has
to be yeah started or it's the way it
always works there's elements I totally
miss but it's not that you won't ever
find it more so than ever there's
everything under the Sun and hip-hop is
like the new punk rock like it's really
captivated people and what it is and
what it can be is so many more things
than it ever used to be in this times
I feel like any time you have
generations at all yeah people are just
going to gravitate towards what was
around when they were younger you know
like people are always resistant to
change to some degree and there is kind
of a chasm between the perspectives this
all goes hand in hand with a whole
different side of music which is the
lives of black people in America though
what rap meant for black people in
America is something I'll never fully
comprehend simply because I'm not a
black man in America
yeah with rap being a top genre and is
also the only that I can think of right
now and I might sound ignorant a [ __ ]
saying it might sound super ignorant
saying this but when I think about art
forms in the entertainment industry when
I look back at like Sammy Davis jr. when
he was coming up killer bar you know cuz
I remember those days when Sammy Davis
jr. was doing that he was the black guy
in this media and it can often be that
way for a black man in a lot of
different professions but rap has become
the art form that you primarily
associate with the black experience yeah
so that when there's a white guy doing
this more like there's a white guy yeah
that was very apparent yeah when rap has
evolved and changed and has become what
it is now I imagine the conversation to
be something that is very passionate and
very personal because of what rap has
meant for black people in the community
and like I said I could be very ignorant
as all my not black observations I've
made over the course of being around rap
in my life you know that's something I
think is at the core of all this just
the experiences of the different
generations what rap is worth and what
it means as an art form as a form of
expression as a business as any other
stuff is just really different Admira
cordy for basically making the effort to
not just come out and be like screw you
guys but trying to take this more
constructive angle because he does point
out like hey some of the old idols have
proven themselves to be pretty messed up
people but also you should be happier
that we're using this to achieve our
success just like the old heads did
ya know it's kind of telltale of what I
imagine is just a change in the culture
and the lifestyle you know look all I
know is when evena lies back yeah he can
really set this record straight mean a
boyband of Mike Shinoda Vanilla Ice
mclemore yeah atmosphere atmosphere
Eminem Eminem G easy and Machine Gun
Kelly the flow BOTS got Jeff Oh uncle
anims uncle Adam
we need the boys from dynamite hack yeah
just to really redirect the conversation
way that song has meant to be heard mess
up the conversation as much as why are
all these white people banding together
and rap and my last note is I just want
to say about that cardi B line my
girlfriend listens to cardi B so much
cardi these songs are all about your
[ __ ] up boyfriend not the great weird
like driving a car biz she's like wrap
it along there's a lot of fire in those
bars like doing some really like to me
personally should I be like downloading
this album and study yeah what's your
opinion on rap today do you miss it do
you wish it would go back to the way it
was do you like these new tunes what's
your favorite rap music video that are
kind of like porn you guys can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification bell check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A s requests like this one we
watch black lightning we're just going
for all the black shows I'm just trying
to fit in to the community you watch
childish gambino show I love Atlanta
yeah yeah cut your bank I secure it